[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم دعا 51 دبلوماسيا وموظفا رفيعا
في الخارجيه الامريكيه الرئيس بارك اوباما
بالتدخل العسكري في سوريا واستهداف نظام
بشار الاسد لانهاء الحرب وقال اصحاب مذكره
في هذا الشان نشرتها نيويورك تايمز ان
تحركهم ضو دوافع اخلاقيه ويرمي لوقف
المجازر بعد خمس سنوات من حرب رهيبه توقف
مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما دوافع هؤلاء الدبلوماسيين
ودلالات اختيارهم هذا
التوقيت وما مدى واقعيه طلبهم وقدره
اوباما على الاستجابه
له
ليست بالدعوه الاولى الموجهه لاوباما
بالتحرك وكبح جماح الرئيس السوري وما
ترتكبه قواته وحلفاؤها ضد المدنيين منذ
اكثر من خمس سنوات الا انها صرخه قويه من
المطلعين من الداخل على الملف السوري وما
يرون انه طال السكوت على بطش الاسد بشعبه
هم عشرات من الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين
الذين يرون ان سياسه بلاد
تجاه الازمه السوريه ليست فعاله وانه يجب
التصرف لتغيير الوضع القائم في سوريا وما
ينجر عنه من اوضاع وصفوها بالكارثي تقرير
زياد
بركات يكون كيري في كوبنهاجن انه هناك في
جوله اسكندنافيه يتصدرها تاثير تغير
المناخ على القطب الشمالي يسال عن امر لا
علا له بالمناخ بل
بالسياسه لا علاقه له بالطقس البارد بل
باكثر ملفات القرن سخونه على
الاطلاق يسال الرجل اذا عن مذكره وقعها 51
دبلوماسيا في وزارته وتنتقد سياسه اوباما
السوريه فيرى فيها شيئا مهما لا يؤيد
الرجل ولا يعارض موقف اولئك الموظفين
واغلبهم من المستوى المتوسط الى الرفيع
يطالبون وفق ما تسرب بتدخل اكثر فعاليه في
سوريا وتحديدا بضربات عسكريه ضد القوات
الحكوميه السوريه وعلى وجه اكثر تحديدا
يطالبون بما سمي استخداما مدروسا لاسلحه
بعيده المدى واخرى جويه اي باستخدام
صواريخ كروز وطائرات بلا طيار وربما غارات
جويه اذا اقتضى الامر ذلك يستندون في هذا
الى استهانه بشار الاسد باي هدنه تسن
اضافه الى ما هو اهم وهو الموقف الاخلاق
لمثل هذا التحرك الذي من شانه وقف المجازر
وشلال الدم المتدفق في
سوريا اوباما هنا كما كان بالامس غير معني
وفقا لمنتقديه بهذا الموقف فمذ كرات كهذه
لا تغير سياسه البيت الابيض وموقف كالذي
ورد فيها سبق ان سمعه من كبار اركان
ادارته ورفضه ففي عام 2012 اي بعد عام
واحد من اندلاع الثوره السوريه تقدمت
وزيره خارجيته انذاك هيلاري كلينتون
مدعومه بوزير الدفاع ليون بانتا بخطه
لتسليح المعارضه السوريه بما يكفل الاطاحه
ببشار الاسد لكن اوباما تحفظ على الخطه بل
رفضها عمليا وتحدث بعد ذلك عن خط احمر اذا
تجاوزه بشار تغير موقف الاداره الامريكيه
وما هي الا شهور قليله حتى قام الاسد
بهجومه الكيماوي على الغوطه في اغسطس من
عام 2013
انذاك كان على اوباما ان يقصف لكنه انتظر
صفقه ابرمها كيري مع لافروف لتجريد الاسد
من اسلحته الكيميائيه لا يبادر الى خوض
حرب ضد الاسد وهو في بدايه ولايته الثانيه
فهل سيفعلها في شهوره الاخيره في البيت
الابيض سؤال يجيب عليه بالنف ضمن مدير
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه فالاسد
حاليا اقوى بكثير مما كان عليه الحال قبل
سنه واكثر ويعود الفضل في ذلك الى الضربات
الجويه الروسيه لا محاله وهو ما يعني ان
حربا ضد الاسد لم تعد باليسر الذي كانت
عليه من قبل ستكون حربا متعدده ومخاطرها
كبيره واوباما في كل الاحوال لا يريدها
حربا عسكريه حتى لو كانت رشقا بالورود كما
يتهكم بعض
منتقديه لمناقشه موضوع هذه الحلقه ينضم
الينا من اسطنبول خطيب بدله عضو الائتلاف
السوري المعاذ ان يلتحق بنا ضيف اخر في
هذه هذه الحلقه حالما يجهز معنا ابدا
بضيفي من اسطنبول خطيب بدله فيما يتعلق
بهذه المذكره من قبل مجموعه من
الدبلوماسيين في الخارجيه الامريكيه وقيل
بانها بدوافع اخلاقيه تدعو الاداره
الامريكيه الى عدم اطاله عذبات السوريين
كيف وجدتم هذه المذكره من حيث المضمون من
قبل الجهه التي ايضا ارسلتها وكذلك من حيث
التوقيت
يعني يجب علينا ان نتجنب الحديث عن الجانب
الاخلاقي سواء عند الاخوه الذين وقعوا على
هذه المذكره او غيرهم من السياسيين في
العالم لان المذبحه السوريه مستمره منذ
خمس سنوات والجانب الاخلاقي لم يتم تفعيله
او لم يتحرك خلال خمس سنوات وكل العالم
شاهد على شاشات التلفزيون وبخلال بث مباشر
كيف يقتل الرجال والنساء والاطفال ويرفعون
من تحت الانقاض وتهدم البيوت ورات اوروبا
بام عينها كيف تدفق ملايين اللاجئين
السوريين الهاربين من جحيم البراميل
والقصف الروسي والسوري والايراني وحزب
الله والكتائب
الميليشيات الطائفيه التي جاءت لتصفي
حساباتها في سوريا اذا انت تستبعد ان يكون
الدافع اخلاقيا الحاله ما هوع برايك سيد
خطيب
يعني صديقنا الجانب الاخلاقي لا يتجزا
يعني لا يمكن ان يرى الانسان مجزره ومذابح
ثم بعد خمس سنوات يتذكر ان عليه ان يحتج
هذا ما اردت قوله لا نحن لا يعني نجرد
هؤلاء الناس من الاخلاق ولكن نتحدث عن
موضوع ال انيه الاخلاق يعني حينما يكون
يجب ان تظهر يجب ان تظهر لا ان تؤجل اما
الحديث في هذا هذا الشان ممكن يعني النظر
اليه من عده جوانب يعني يمكن ان يكون هو
ليقول كيري والرئيس اوباما انه انا علي
ضغوط والان هذه الضغوط تزداد مع اقتراب
نهايه الانتخابات قد يكون للانتخابات
الامريكيه الصراع بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين علاقه بهذه المذكره على كل
حال هي شيء جيد يعني ولا يمكن ان نعتبرها
يعني شيء يعني امرا ثانويا ولكن الحقيقه
نحن بحاجه الى فعل اسرع واقوى ويعني نحن
نعرف ان بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعني حينما تريد فعلا ان تنهي
الحرب تنهيها لا يمكن ان نستبعد ان انها
قادره على ذلك يعني نحن نعرف ان الروس لهم
حدود في التدخل الروس هم هم دول اقل ش ق
الخو هذه المسه سط قبل الخو هذه المساله
بالنسبه لك هل سياسه الرئيس باراك اوباما
فيما يتعلق بالملف السوري مفهومه وهل كانت
كما انطلقت الثوره وبدا تعاطي النظام
السوري والمواقف الامريكيه هي نفسها كما
هي الان بعد كل هذه
السنوات يعني خلال هذه الفتره كلها سياسه
اوباما هي سياسه برجماتيه تماما يعني لا
يدخل فيها اي جانب من ج
الاخلاق او الانسانيه او حتى الديمقراطيه
يعني الانسان الذي الدوله التي تدعي انها
حامله الديمقراطيه لم تتصرف على هذا
الاساس في سوريا هي سياسه براغماتيه ويبحث
عن نفع لامريكا ويبحث لنفع شخصي ان يعني
تتوج فترته بشيء ما ولذلك حينما يعني
ذهبوا الى فينا في اواخر 2015 كان يريد ان
يكمل فترته التي يعني يعني حاول ان لا
يكون فيها اي فعل عسكري ينهي معاناه الشعب
السوري حاول ان يلهي الناس ان هناك عمليه
سياسيه واستطاع ان يحشد 17 دوله اضافه الى
المنظمات واضافه الى روسيا طبعا وبدا يعني
الاخذ والرد يعني اي تصريحات تشتد و اي
ترتخي هذا ما شاهدناه وفي الفتره الاخيره
فعلا يعني الروس تمادوا كثيرا في قتل
السوريين في تعطيل العمليه السياسيه التي
كانت مستمره في جنيف عطلوها
ببراميل وبالقصر وب
وبالتصوير
هذاب انهم يحاربون داعش والنصره وهم في
الواقع نراهم انهم ع المقاطعه سيد خطيب
وصفت السياسه الامريكيه بانها سياسه
براغماتيه ولكن الرئيس اوباما في حد ذاته
تم نصيحته باكثر من طرف كما شاهدنا في
التقرير قبل قليل نصح من قبل وزيره
خارجيته هيلاري كلينتون ونصح ايضا من قبل
قاده عسكريين والان ترفع له مذكره من قبل
مجموعه من الدبلوماسيين تطالبه بتغيير
النهج في سوريا بين البراغماتيه وبين
نصائح هؤلاء من الخارجيه والدفاع فيما
يتعلق بالاداره الامريكيه هل هناك رؤيه
واضحه ام تخبط امريكي فيما يتعلق بمتابعه
ومعالجه الملف
السوري يعني انا شخصيا استبعد موضوع
التخبط هذه السياسه التي يمشي عليها
اوباما هي سياسه مقصوده بذاتها يعني هو
حينما اراد ان يوجه ضربه محدوده للاسد بعد
موضوع الكيماوي في نهايه 2013 في تقريبا
شهر اغسطس
يعني سبتمبر هو فعلا كان جادا في المساله
يريد ان يوجه ضربه محدوده ولكن النظام
السوري هو نظام شبه متداعي يعني ضربه اقل
من التي وعد بها اوباما كاف لاسقاطه لانه
هناك عمليه انهيار ت تتسارع حينما تبدا
يعني ولذلك هرع يعني الروس لايجاد تسويه
تقديم رشوه لاوباما انه نعطيك كل الترسانه
ال ال كيماويه الموجوده في سوريا والتي
صرف عليها الاسد الاب والابن
مليارات من اجل قتل الشعب السوري طبعا لم
يصرفوا هذه المليارات ليقيموا ترسان
عسر هذ المسه بالضافه الى موضوع حلقتنا
فيما يتعلق بالمذكره المرفوعه من مجموعه
من الدبلوماسيين في الخارجيه الامريكيه
ولكن دعونا نرحب بضيفنا الذي التحق بنا
الان من واشنطن السفير جيمس جيفري نائب
مستشار الامن القوم الامريكي سابقا لنسال
عن هذه المذكره الوزير كريي وصفها بال
المهمه فهل هي فعلا مهمه خاصه وانه قيل
بانها بدوافع اخلاقيه وما الذي يه
ذلك اولا انا فخور بالاشخاص الذين كتبوا
هذه المذكره وهم زملاء قمام لي وهذا امر
رغم ان ننا في وزاره الخارجيه يمثل خطرا
على الموظفين وربما لا يتفق الوزير مع كل
ما فيها ولكن رغم ذلك اعترف بانها خطوه
مهمه هؤلاء الدبلوماسيون هم من يعمل يوميا
على تنفيذ سياستنا في سوريا والمفاوضات مع
الروس والسوريين وشاهدوا انها السياسه
حاليا لا تحقق اي شيء بل فقط تبرر لروسيا
ما تقوم به لكي تساعد اسد والاخرين لحق نص
عسكري على حساب مئات الالاف من السوريين
وهذا امر مخزي وغير مقبول وهذا ما يقول
الدبلوماسيون للشعب الامريكي وبشكل علني
اذا اتفقنا بانها خطوه اخلاقيه كما قال
موقع هذه المذكره ماذا عن توقيتها الم
تاتي متاخره
كثيرا سيد
جفري كلا ان في امريكا الوقت ليس متاخرا
ابدا صراحه انا شاهدت ما حصل في البوسنا
ولدينا ايضا
موظف في الاداره الامريكيه ايضا الخارجيه
قاموا بنفس العمل عندما قت مئات الالاف
الناس في عام 992 و93 و94
و95 رفعوا اصواتهم وبالنتيجه في النهايه
حصلت تغييرات وادى ذلك الى تحسين الموقف
وبالتالي يمكن يتحسن الموقف غدا اذا ما
تصرفنا الروس لن يدخلوا في حرب معنا
لانقاذ اسد بل لا يدخل يدخل الحرب فقط
لانقاذ مواقفهم في سوريا ولكن هذا ليس
هناك تحدي لذلك من قبلنا فقط
نريد ان روسيا مقبوله كما تنص قرارات مجلس
الامن لكن ما تقوم به روسيا هو انكار ما
اتفقت عليه ووافقت عليه
وبدات تستخدم كل جهودها لتحقيق نصر عسكري
للنظام ولن نسمح بذلك لم يستجب ولم يتجاوب
الرئيس الامريكي باراك اوباما في دعوات
سابقه في سنه سابقه فيما يتعلق بنفس الملف
الملف السوري نصح من قبل قيادات في ادارته
ما الذي يجعله هذه المره يغير رايه ويغير
نهجه هذا سؤال وجيه ولكنني لا بقوم ببعض
التمييز استخدام القوه العسكريه لبدل
الضغط او التهديد باستخدام القوه العسكريه
لضغط على السوريين او الروس او الايرانيين
هذا ليس بالجديد قمنا بذلك مع الاوكرانيين
ومع الايران الاتفاق النووي وكما ذكر
مراسلكم قبل ذلك في
موضوع الاسلحه الكيمياويه السوريه لكن
المشكله هنا هي ليست فقط عدم استخدام
القوى العسكريه بل استمرار هذه المفاوضات
اوباب حد الادنى كان امكانه ان يوقف
المفاوضات مع الروس ويطردهم ويقول لهم
انكم لا تتفاوض بنوايا حسنه وانتم فقط
تقدمون ذرائع للاداره الامريكيه لكي لا
تقوموا باي شيء ولكن كما قلت دون اي دون
اي تقدم ودون
السماح ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه وافقت
عليه الامم المتحده فان هذا الامر تصبح
سياسه هذه المفاوضات تصبح
سياسه الفاء الشرعيه على ما تقوم به الروس
يقوم به الروس وكانهم يجعلهم يبدون وكانهم
جزء من الحل في حين انهم في الواقع جزء من
الاخفاق في التوصل الى حل وبالتالي على
على اوباما ان يعيد النظر في سياسه
المهادنه هذه مع الروس لان الامر كله
يتعلق بهذا سيد خطيب بدله انتم انت عضو في
الائتلاف السوري المعارض متابع بشكل مباشر
للضو الامريكي فيما يتعلق ب الوضع في
سوريا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طرف
محايد طرف مشارك طرف وسيط كيف
تصفونه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لها
موقف شديد الوضوح من القضيه السوريه ان
القضيه السوريه لا تحل الا بالمسائل
السياس بالطرق السياسيه ومن خلال عمليه
سياسيه ولكن لا وجود للاسد في في المراحل
القادمه
هي ربما تقبل بالمناور مع مقابل الروس حول
فتره وجود الاسد او الى اي حد لكنها لا
تقبل ببقائه وهذا هو هو ايضا منسجم مع
الموقف السعودي الذي دائما صر على ان
الاسد يجب ان يرحل باي طريقه ولكن بالنسبه
للامريكان فعلا تساهلوا كثيرا في هذه
العمليه نحن نتوقع ان هناك اتفاقا غير
معلن بين الامريكان والروس علما ان
الامريكان ينفون وجود اي اتفاق سري حينما
يكون هناك لقاءات بيننا وبينهم يقولون لا
يوجد شيء اتفاق سري ولكن هل يعقل ان يفشل
وقف اطلاق النار الذي توصلت اليه امريكا
وروسيا ان ت تنتهك ينتهكه الطرف الموقع
عليه اللي هو الروس يوميا وبعش الغارات
والامريكان يرون ذلك ونعتبر انه لا يوجد
اتفاق بينهم هذا امر فعلا يعني يحتاج الى
كثير من الزاجه لكي نستطيع ان نصدقه ولكن
الحقيقه ان الاوام بالنسبه لاوباما قد فات
لانه خلال شهر قادم او خلال شهرين قادمين
ستبدا ال العمليه الانتخابيه في امريكا
ولن
يكون الجمهوريون ولا
الديمقراطيون منتبهين الى ما يجري في
سوريا سيكونون مشغولين
ب واعتقد ان من هذه الحلقه ولكن دعني قبل
ان ننتقل للمحور الثاني في هذه الحلقه
اسال ضيفي من واشنطن السيد جيفري فيما
يتعلق بذه الوثيقه هذه المبادره هي مستاءه
من السياسه سياسه الرئيس اوباما في سوريا
ولكن هل تكلمت عن البديل عن الطريقه
الاخرى التي يجب ان تكون نهجا للاداره
الامريكيه في
سوريا نعم نعم اولا انا لا اتفق مع الخطيب
واعتقد ان علينا وسوف نتحدث ايضا عن سيريا
في سوريا في الحمله الانتخابيه لان اكبر
اخفاق في السياسه الخارجيه في اداره
اوباما وهي خطر على امريكا كما هي خطر على
كل المنطقه وعلى اوروبا ما يدعو عليه
هؤلاء الناس لم اشاهد رسالتهم لكن شاهدنا
تسريبات منها هو المزيد من القوه العسكريه
بعضه يكون بعضه يكون خطر وبعضه قد يكون
على سبيل تاسيس مناطق
امنه وكثيرون اوصوا بما فيهم انا وضع
اوصنا بوضع الضغوط على روسيا وايران وهم
لا يدعون الى اطاحه باسد فقط يدعون الى
موازنه بين الثقل
الروس وايران وحزب الله والاسد
والثوار او المعارضه الذي يمثلهم الضيف
الاخر من جانب الاخر وهذا موقف معقول يمكن
ان ينجح ونجح في النزاعات الاخرى في
العالم فصل قصير نناقش بعده مدى واقعيه
طلب الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين التدخل
عسكريا ضد النظام السوري وقدره اوباما على
الاستجابه له ابقوا معنا
رجاء
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش فيها دلالات مطالبه 50 من
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين في الخارجيه طبعا
الامريكيه الرئيس اوباما بضرب نظام الاسد
ومدى واقعيه وجدوى هذه الخطوه ارحب بضيفي
من واشنطن وكذلك من اسطنبول ضيفي من
واشنطن السيد جيمس جيفري ذكرت قبل قليل
بتفاؤل بانه بالامكان لو تم الاستجابه غدا
و لمطالب هؤلاء الدبلوماسيين التحرك بشكل
مختلف فيما يتعلق بالملف السوري ما مدى
واقعيه ما طرحته في ظل ان الرئيس اوباما
لم يبقى له الا ايام في البيت
الابيض الرئاسات قد تتغير وكن امريكا
وليست ديكتاتوريه
فنحن بلد ديمق مراطي عام فيه مناقشات
مفتوحه علنيه حول ما ينبغي ان تكون عليه
سياساتنا وبالتالي ف للشعب راي كبير
وتاثير على ما ينبغي ان يحصل وهذه رساله
سيكون لها تاثير كبير على الراي العام
يمكن لرئيس اوباما ان يتجاهلها ويقول انه
على حق ولكن لمواصله سياسته الحاليه في
ليس فقط تجاهل الضغوط العسكريه على اسد بل
الاستمرار في هذه عمليه المهادنه
في المفاوضات مع الروس لا يؤدي الى اي شيء
وهو مصدر احراج كبير الولايات المتحده
بامكانه ان ينهي ذلك على الاقل وذلك سيؤدي
الى توضيح الموقف الى حد كبير ذكرت ايضا
قبل قليل بان الملف السوري يشكل نقطه
سوداء في اداره الرئيس الامريكي باراك
اوباما الا يمكن ان يستغل هذا ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالحمله الانتخابيه وبالتالي هذه
المبادره هذه الدعوه جزء مما ينفق في
الحملات الانتخابيه
الامريكيه نعم بالكيد كل هدف الحمله
السياسيه هو ليس فقط اختيار شخص من ما
ليكون رئيسا بل ايضا لكي يستطيع الشعب
الامريكي ان يعبر عن رايه حول الخيارات
المطروح عليه في السياسات المحليه
والخارجيه ومواضيع الحرب والسلام وبالتالي
هذه الرساله تعتبر مساهمه وبالتالي فهي
فهؤلاء الاشخاص هم يعرضون مسيرتهم
الوظيفيه للخطر فانهم استخدموا خبراتهم
الرائعه لنقلها الى نقل ارائهم الى الوزير
بشكل عام ليقوله رجاء اعد النظر في سياسات
وهذه خطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح سيد خطيب
بدله الاداره الامريكيه لم تتدخل كما يجب
او على الاقل تجاوبا مع مبادره
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه في بدايه الازمه
السوريه عندما كانت اقل تعقيدا الان
الازمه هي الاعقد على الصعيد الدولي
وبالتالي ما مدى قدره هذه الدعوه ان تشكله
فارقا
الان يعني اولا انا لا اقلل من شان هذه
الدعوه وقد يعني ذكرت ان يعني ه يعني لو
انها جاءت متاخره الا انها جيده ونحن فعلا
يجب علينا ان نشعر بالامتنان لهؤلاء الناس
على قيامهم بهذا الواج الاخلاقي المتاخر
ولكن هناك احتمالان يعني احتمال ان تكون
هذه القصه لها علاقه فقط في الانتخابات
الامريكيه ولتحسين تحسين صوره
الديمقراطيين في الانتخابات على انهم لم
يعني يريدون ان يمحوا النقطه السوداء التي
التصقت بهم من خلال السياسه السلبيه
لاداره
اوباما اذا كان نح انا اريد ان اقول ان ان
الحل في نهايه المط طاف بالنسبه لسوريا
للحرب الدائره في سوريا على تعقيداته لن
يكون الا باراده امريكيه انا هذا ما
اعتقده شخصيا لان سواء اوباما او الذي
سياتي وراء اوباما اذا لم تتدخل امريكا
وهي قادره على فعل شيء بالكلام اكثر من
الفعل يعني حينما طيب باعتبار المساله في
او لم يستخدم
القوه لم ستخدم لحظه لم لان الوقت همنا
استسمحك عذرا سيد جيفري في هذه الحاله هل
تعتقد بان الرئيس اوباما
سيتجاوز وما شكل هذا
التجاوب هذه الرساله تضعه في موقف صعب فهو
يعتقد انه محق في سياسته السوريه ولكنه
يدرك وكبار مساعديه يدركون بان هذه
السياسه قد ادت الى اولا قدر كبير من
القتلى المدنيين
وثانيا زياده القوه والنفوذ الايراني
والروسي مما يتحدى الوضع القائم في الشرق
الاوسط وتالي فهو سوف يقع تحت ضغوط كبيره
جدا للتصرف ازاء كل ذلك وايضا لو خذنا
ضفنا ذلك الهجوم في
اورلاندو من الواضح ان الشعب الامريكي لن
يكون مستعيدا بما يحصل في الشرق الاوسط
وهو رئيس السياسه كنت
معنا واشنطن السفير جيمس جيفري نائب
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي سابقا كما
اشكر ضيفي من اسطنبول خطيب بدله عضو
الائتلاف السوري المعارض ا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج م وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن
الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا